WORK DONE BY LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
MY HEART GOES OUT TO GEORGE’S
FAMILY AND FRIENDS.
JUSTICE WILL BE SERVED.
GOVERNOR CHRIS CHRISTIE, FORMER
GOVERNOR CHRISTIE OF NEW JERSEY
IS WITH US.
GOVERNOR, YOU KNOW, I UNDERSTAND
MIKE TOBIN JUST INTERVIEWED A
GUY EXTREMELY ARTICULATE AND
PASSIONATE ABOUT HOW HE FEELS.
A GUY THAT HAS SERVED HIS
COUNTRY.
AND I SEE THE CROWDS THERE.
I SAW THIS GUY WAS ARMED.
AND I THINK ABOUT ALL THE PEOPLE
IN THE CITY, AND I THINK ABOUT
WHAT IS HAPPENING.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN THE PROCESS OF
WHAT THE PRESIDENT IS EXPEDITING
A AN INVESTIGATION MEANS IN THE
HOPES THAT GOOD PEOPLE WON’T GET
HURT AND IN THESE PROTESTS WERE
ANY INNOCENT PEOPLE HURT.
>> ABSOLUTELY, SEAN.
WHAT THE PRESIDENT WILL NOW HAVE
DONE IS DIRECTOR CHRIS WRAY WILL
PUT A FLIGHT OF FBI AGENTS BOTH
FROM THE FIELD OFFICE IN
MINNEAPOLIS AND FROM THE
HEADQUARTERS IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
TO INTERVIEW ANYONE WHO WAS IN
THE CROWD, ANYONE IN THE AREA
ATTEMPTING THE OFFICERS
INVOLVED THEMSELVES MAY OR MAY
NOT PERMIT THEMSELVES TO BE
INTERVIEWED IF ALREADY RETAINED
A LAWYER’S WHICH I SUSPECT THEY
HAVE.
LOOK AT ALL THE FORENSIC
EVIDENCE, AND THEN IMMEDIATELY
GO TO THE U.S. ATTORNEY IN
MINNESOTA WHO HAS ALREADY
ASSIGNED A COMPETENT ASSISTANT
U.S. ATTORNEYS TO WORK WITH THE
FBI ON THIS CASE AND TO GET IT
IN FRONT OF A GRAND JURY AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
AND THAT IS WHAT THEY WILL BE
DOING RIGHT NOW.
THE ONLY WAY TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN
QUICKLY IS TO THROW A LOT OF
RESOURCES AT IT.
I’M CONFIDENT THAT
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR INSTRUCTED
THE U.S. ATTORNEY TO DO THAT
WHEN IT COMES TO PROSECUTORS.
TO DIRECTOR CHRIS WRAY WHEN IT
APPLIES TO AGENTS.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW THIS IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE TOO.
YOU HAVE WORKED IN DIFFERENT
FORMS OF BEING IN CHARGE OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND I THINK IT
IS IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND.
I LOCKED THERE TALKED ABOUT THE
1% OF PEOPLE THAT ABUSE THEIR
POWER AND/OR CORRUPT AND WE SEE
DAMAGE OF 1%.
THAT HAS NOT BEEN MY EXPERIENCE
IN LAW ENFORCEMENT.
IT IS THE OPPOSITE.
THE 99% THAT DO THEIR JOB AND
PROTECT AND SERVE HERE AND I
KNOW AT MOMENTS LIKE THIS,
PEOPLE FORGET THAT PART, BUT
LET’S TOO ALSO, WHERE IS THE
TRAINING OF THESE GUYS?
HOW DO YOU NOT KNOW THE NECK IS
THAT SENSITIVE?
>> SEAN, WHERE IS THE OFFICERS
THAT ARE STANDING NEAR THIS GUY
WHO ARE WILLING TO STAND UP AND
STOP HIM?
YOU KNOW, THAT IS THE PROBLEM
TOO.
YOU KNOW, THIS GUY IS DOING WHAT
HE DOES IS AWFULLY LAX, BUT IT
IS JUST AS AWFUL TO HEAR HIM SAY
HE CANNOT BREATHE WHILE
HANDCUFFED ON THE GROUND AND NOT
INTERVENE AND STOP YOUR FELLOW
OFFICERS FROM DOING IT.
YOUR OBLIGATION TO THE LAW
APPLIES NOT JUST TO THE CITIZENS
THAT YOU ARE PROTECTING EVERY
DAY, IT APPLIES TO MAKING SURE
THAT LAW IS ENFORCED AGAINST